We'll take a quick quick break and be back
right after this.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.
Welcome back to the David Pakman show today.
Welcoming to the program, Barbara Freese,
who's an environmental attorney, energy analyst
and author of the recently released book Industrial
Strength Denial Eight Stories of Corporations
Defending the Indefensible From the Slave
Trade to Climate Change.
Barbara, it's great to have you on today.
Thanks for having me, David.
So this is this is a theme, this idea of denial.
It's a strategy, really.
And whenever there is a disagreement in culture,
in politics, wherever, sometimes the facts
are debated.
But sometimes you see a strategy of simply
simply denying the facts, saying those are
not the facts, or I don't believe what you
are presenting me sort of an equivalent to
bearing one's head in the sand as it may be.
How far back does this sort of grift of denial
go as you've charted and researched it?
Well, I went back as far as the slave trade
and a challenge to it in Britain in the late
seventeen hundreds and early eighteen hundreds.
I do think of this as a part of human psychology.
So I think it goes back as long as as we've
been humans.
But as far as a documented industry campaign
of denial, we know that it's at least as old
as the slave trade.
And what were the arguments made around the
slave trade?
They were appalling and absurd.
They basically embraced this kind of rescue
narrative that they were not, you know, enslaving
people, they weren't taking captives from
Africa and putting them on horrible plantations.
On the contrary, they were rescuing them from
a worse fate in Africa where they would have
been put to death as prisoners of war or eaten
by cannibals and delivering them to, you know,
first of all, on a lovely festive slave ship
to a very comfortable plantation where they
would be well treated and have comfortable
homes and be taken care of in in old age and
sickness.
And it was it was really appalling.
And because this was the British trade and
the British dominated the trade, they were
speaking to an audience that had no direct
experience at all of slavery.
So they could really get away with with some
whoppers that they couldn't have gotten away
with in the United States, where people at
least saw something of slavery.
I've even heard in the last few years that
typically from folks from certain political
persuasions in the United States, I'm not
for slavery.
But conditions for some freed slaves were
worse than with certain slave owners, which
seems sort of like a similar idea.
Well, and in fact, that was a strategy that
the British slave traders used.
They frequently compared the conditions that
slaves lived under with the poor in Britain.
And, of course, the poor in Britain did live
under terrible conditions.
So it was sort of an example of sort of this
downward ratchet that that as long as there
were bad conditions for one group, you could
use that as an excuse to allow even worse
conditions for another group.
Very present right now when we talk about
denial is climate, climate science and climate
science denial.
And you write about this in the book.
I've been covering it for a very long time.
Is there something unique to climate science
denial, maybe either from a psychological
perspective or in some way that distinguishes
it from the other?
Denial grifts that you've covered?
Or is it just another version of the same
sort of thing?
Well, pretty much all the climate denial denials
that we see have appeared in other industries
over the decades and centuries.
But there are some things about climate denial
that I think make it just particularly easy.
One of them is that it is such a huge problem.
It is such a long term problem.
It is something that everybody contributes
to at least a little bit in terms of consuming
fossil fuels.
And that's such a familiar thing that our
minds are not really triggered to be afraid
of, of things that are that familiar.
And another thing I think that makes this
unusual is just the phenomenal success of
climate denial.
I mean, you never heard presidents of the
United States, at least in the modern era,
denying that tobacco caused cancer.
But you have heard at least one of them calling
climate change a hoax.
Yeah, that that's interesting because some
of the same people one of the phenomena that
I find interesting about the climate prospect
climate issue is we know what the science
is and we know it's overwhelming.
And at this point, it's like almost a cliché
to repeat it time and time again.
But the people that deny it seem to accept
uncritically the claims of some small sliver
of scientists they can find or they in other
words, they seem to not apply the same critiques
to those that happen to share their preexisting
notion.
And I've not found a good way to break through
that kind of epistemological barrier when
I talk to those people.
All right.
One of the things I write about in the book
is basically tribalism and its effect on the
mind and how easily triggered it is and then
how incredibly powerful it is.
So in times of uncertainty, in times of conflict,
it becomes particularly strong.
And certainly the level of skepticism you
would apply to people outside your tribe becomes
very, very high.
And the level of skepticism you apply to those
within your tribe, telling you what you want
to hear is very, very low.
It's also a sort of exaggerated confirmation
bias that we all indulge in personally.
But that gets amplified in times like this
when the issue is this big and when the industry
in question is really, you know, one of the
most or maybe the most powerful industry in
the world and where you're talking about harms
that are really inherent in its central product,
in that sense, it's kind of like tobacco.
And, you know, interestingly, the big oil
companies now, just like Big Tobacco, don't
deny anymore the fundamental facts of their
product causing harm.
And yet they have been denied.
For so many decades and put in place so many
barriers to regulation that they're still
benefiting from decades of denial passed what
seems to be effective in getting through the
denial?
I mean, I'm thinking of, you know, with coronaviruses
an example.
Initially, when there were some cases in China,
it was very easy to just say it won't come
here.
And then it did.
And it's very easy to say there won't be a
lot of cases and they'll go away.
And then there's lots of cases.
But you say, well, we're not going to have
a lot of deaths and then there's deaths.
And then people will say, listen, I'm hearing
that people are dying, but I'm not seeing
the bodies.
And then you see the news video of the mass
graves being dug and the refrigerated trucks.
And people say that's optics produced to trick
people for political reasons like there.
There's always that ability to say it's stage
managed, it's fake, whatever.
What is effective at getting past all of that?
I wish I could give you a formula that that
made it clear what's effective.
It does seem to matter to have facts and to
have imagery and to bring that before the
public.
What tends to be most effective in overcoming
denial is for there to no longer be any real
credible benefit to denial.
So, for example, that's, I think, what brought
the tobacco industry finally into, you know,
the modern era, because it was to the point
where nobody believed them anyway.
And they're being sued for fraud.
And they had all kinds of other problems.
And they realized that admitting that their
product killed people wasn't really going
to prevent them from selling it.
Even after decades of saying if this was true,
we'd stop selling it.
So that tends to be what happens.
I I'd like to imagine that eventually when
it comes to larger efforts to overcome denial,
if you think of us as being very tribal and
taking on kind of a herd mentality, then perhaps
when people who are at the head of the herd
switch, it might lead to some some greater
acceptance.
You might look at the the George Floyd protests,
which isn't really the same thing.
But but you had the video of his killing.
Right.
And I think that helped a lot of members of
the public who had no financial or ideological
stake in this one way or another, but except
that they wanted to believe the world was
no better than it is when they saw that.
I think a certain amount of public denial
about just how bad things could be went away.
So I do tend to be a big believer in evidence
and and trying to bring that out there, even
though we do have a lot of examples of it
failing to convince people.
How much of a problem do you see the corporate
media coverage of some of these issues being
and the spin?
The example I'm thinking of is although the
science on climate is, you know, ninety nine
point nine eight to zero point zero two or
however lopsided it is, you want to claim
it is, it's somewhere in that range.
You have numerous and regular corporate media
debates where you have two people and they're
given equal time.
And one person, 50 percent of the debate represents
the ninety nine point nine, eight and 50 percent
of the debate, meaning one person represents
the point zero two.
It's this sort of false balance problem, which
I think corporate media engages in in order
to be neutral, as they say.
But neutral is not objective.
And so I'm wondering how much you think that
contributes to some of this denial and provides
cover?
Yeah, I think that has always been a problem
when it comes to particularly climate change.
I mean, even if you were to try to do it in
some more balanced way and for example, you
were to have a debate with ninety nine climate
scientists who recognized the threat and one
who denied it.
I think that the audience would still come
away saying, oh, well, then there are two
different opinions.
So I think you're right that pretty much any
attention to what is now a very much discredited
viewpoint gives it more credibility with the
public and particularly with the public.
That is not scientific and not fully aware
of all the data, because you can never really
convey all the data or the strength of it
to a nonscientific public when it comes to
something like coal, which relates to the
climate debate more generally in that certainly,
you know, if you disbelieve the science on
climate, you might be more supportive of coal
because of its immediate sort of monetary
benefits and that it's cheap and we don't
need new infrastructure like we would with
solar or wind or whatever the case may be.
How have you seen or sort of observed the
coal debate happened during the current administration
where we've seen the president essentially
say that he wants to take take this out of
the market?
The free market, of course, pointing to letting
coal die to revitalize an industry that from
a climate perspective, doesn't make sense.
Where does this fit into the discussion in
terms of people who who say, yes, we should
we really should bring coal back?
Is it a denial of the climate science?
Is it a sort of political or tribal based
reaction, some combination of the two?
Yeah, I think it's it's certainly a combination
of the two.
And it's certainly a reflection of the fact
that to the extent the coal industry has been
defending itself in the past by saying that
you should let the market decide.
Right.
That sort of ideological justification for
burning coal really wasn't what was ever motivating
them.
And in fact, what the president has tried
to do is to get power companies to buy coal
and subsidized coal even when they would prefer
not to.
So so that was a pretty clear illustration
that the ideological justification was never.
Really, what was driving it?
The last thing I want to touch a touch on
is I think if we didn't mention this, we would
be missing a huge piece of this, which is
the denial side is often very well-funded.
And when you think back to tobacco and I forget
it.
What if it was the Clean Skies or Clean Air
Initiative or whatever, which was basically
about convincing restaurant owners, hey, if
you want freedom from regulation, we need
you on board so that people will be allowed
to smoke inside your restaurants when the
Movement for No Smoking in restaurant started.
These are really well-funded movements and
that seems to dramatically skew a lot of the
conversations that are happening.
Does it not?
Oh, sure.
I mean, the industries that I wrote about
and I focus just on eight industries and most
of the really big ones.
They had enormous amounts of money to promote
their viewpoint, to give to other free market
ideological groups, to promote their views
more secretly, to hire people, to write articles,
but not to explain where they got the money.
And then ultimately, you end up with an entire
industry that supports other industries that
are trying to be tried to deny the science.
So you've got that the law firms, the PR firms,
the advertising agencies and these so-called
nonprofits that that become advocates to oppose
regulation.
So, I mean, I try to write about this partly
from a kind of psychological perspective,
looking at the social science.
And I think what happens is that for the individuals
in the corporations that confront these charges,
that there is a very natural, instinctive
inclination to deny it, which is just part
of human nature.
I think it then moves pretty quickly into
a corporate strategy and then it moves from
there into its own kind of a denial industry
with the same PR firms and others appearing
again and again.
And then I think it moves into an ideology.
And so it's that progression that makes denial,
this very human thing, but but promoted by
these very powerful institutions, such a destructive
thing.
Do you have any insights into the psychology
of the cogs in the wheel, so to speak, that
are carrying out a lot of these that these
denial campaigns?
Because I could imagine a situation where
the people working at the PR firm or the people
working at a corporation or the law firm at
the individual level.
Many of them probably know that what they're
doing is lying and that they're denying what
what what are the facts?
Is it as simple as.
Listen, I'm a cog in the wheel.
I'm just trying to put food on the table.
And this is going to happen regardless.
Or what have you had any insights into that
at the individual level?
I think that is definitely part of it.
And corporations themselves, especially the
big ones younger that are designed to make
the individual not feel responsible for what
the corporation does.
It does that through division of labor.
You're just a cog in the wheel.
And we know for sure that diminishes your
impure feelings of responsibility for the
consequences.
You've got management divided from ownership.
You've got this ideology that tells managers
that their only responsibility is to maximize
shareholder pressure and shareholder profit.
Meanwhile, shareholders don't feel responsible
because they're far away.
It's transactional.
They may just own the stock for a little while
and they don't know what's going on anyway.
We also know that power tends to focus the
mind on your most salient goals, which, if
you're at a corporate executive, is profit.
It also, there's some evidence seems to reduce
your risk awareness and your risk perception
once you become aware of it and your general
social responsibility.
Again, there's the tribalism, the competitiveness
inherent in incorporations, the market mindset.
So, yeah, there's there are a lot of psychological
things you could point to.
In fact, I suggest in the book that if you
are a supervillain trying to get the world
to destroy itself by taking crazy risks, you
might just create a society very much like
our corporate dominated market society, because
there are many, many things there that undermine
our innate sense of social responsibility.
Very well said.
The book is Industrial Strength Denial Eight
Stories of Corporations Defending the Indefensible
from the Slave Trade to Climate Change.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Barbara.
Barbara, thank you so much for your time today.
Thank you, David.
I appreciate it.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot.com.